[Musique]
la
ferme archibal vrenier c'est mon grand
[Musique]
papi je
suischibier si tu regardes ce
kinétoscope c'est que tu es Monique
légitime héritier ou que tu es un [ __ ]
de voleur au quel cas remet cette vidéo
en place [ __ ] de voleur grand secret à
découvrir j'ai découvert que le jeu
Indiana Jones est la clé n'hésite pas à
utiliser mon can la clé je compte sur
toi réussi là où j'ai échoué bonne
chance mon
[Musique]
petitfs
etz for son
[Musique]
GR 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
ouais bon ben il est gentil mais desj
ind il y en a plein quoi tu dois choisir
judicieusement pourquoi tu es habillé
comme ça j'avais plus rien à me mettre
bon alors ça sert à rien parce que c'est
évident que tout le monde connaît mais
je vais quand même vous parler d'Indiana
Jones les films c'est évidemment la
série de films d'aventure la plus connue
et la plus épique réalisée à ce jour il
suffit juste d'entendre ces quelques
notes là et ça y est vous sentez monter
en vous l'envie d'aventure de tuer des
nazis et de défoncer des aborygènes et
si vous êtes un petit jeune qui ne
l'avit pas encore vu alors laissez
tomber cette vidéo tout de suite je vous
y autorise et foncez les voir c'est
vraiment une des meilleures trilogies du
cinéma quoi trilogie il faudra me couper
les couilles avec un sécateur rouillé
trempé dans du vinaigre avant que je
reconnaisse que le 4è film fasse partie
de la saga concernant les jeux vidéos la
hype Indiana Jones maintenant elle est
un peu terminée faut avouer à part pour
quelques jeux Lego la grosse mode
Indiana Jones c'était surtout à l'époque
des 8 et 16 bit il y avait pas mal de
bons jeux et pas mal de jeux pourri
aussi mais quel était le jeu le plus
pourri d'entre tous et ben on va
chercher allez
[Musique]
bon ben celui-là c'est le dernier jeu
alors écoute si c'est pas le
[Musique]
bon qu' a-t-il que mon fidèle CHP
urbain alors c'est parti pour instrument
il y a staring yidia Jones aussi je
l'avais pas vu parce qu'ils l'ont mis
tout en bas et en tout petit comme s'ils
en avaient un peu honte vous savez yidia
Jones alors je vais pas perdre du temps
vous l'expliquer c'est simplement une
série qui est pas mauvaise mais qui est
plutôt moyenne dans l'inspiration vient
de la scène d'intro de las Crusade où on
voit India Jones qui est jeune il y a
pas eu beaucoup de jeux dessus un plutôt
bon sur NES et il y a eu ça en cherchant
un peu sur le net on peut trouver ce qui
ressemble à une version beta
complètement agerbé d'un jeu megga drive
intitulé j Jon Chronicle comme le titre
de la série alors je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé exactement j'avoue mais ma
théorie c'est qu'ils se sont retrouvés
avec un jeu totalement à chier que du
coup on leur a refusé les droits de la
licence ce qui a eu pour effet que le
jeu est passé d'un young India Jones
Chronicle en gros à un autre titre qui
n'avait rien à voir et le nom du héros
en tout petit je n'ai absolument aucune
preuve c'est juste ma théorie bullshit
mais je l'aime bien bon bref donc Jung
India Jones c'est un jeu d'action
plateforme et très sincèrement je crois
avoir vérifié 10 fois sur le net pour
m'assurer que c'était un vrai jeu parce
que j'en reviens toujours pas j'hésite
même à dire que c'est peut-être le pire
jeu de plateforme qu'on a jamais testé
dans un G je veux dire je sais pas trop
si je dois le placer devant ou derrière
dragon slir ou Fantasia mais je ressens
exactement vous savez la
même perte d'intérêt pour la vie quand
j'y joue allez donc c'est parti donc com
armonade des grenades un fling et
que qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bruit de
fouet du tier
monde on dirait même pas un effet sonore
on dirait
elle est bonne attendez je vous
reconnais c'est pas vous qui avez fait
les pour
excalibure allez donc le jeu com oh
c'était quoi ce missile là [ __ ]
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là mais dégage
[ __ ] je suis en train d'essayer de
trouver les boutons là merde dégage toi
c'est quoi ce cauchemar d'entrée de jeu
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
violence gratuite là j'en suis à peine à
me demander quel bouton fait quoi et le
jeu est déjà en train de me Terraformer
le trou du cul sérieusement c'est quand
même délirant le premier ennemi du jeu
que je crois c'est ça
mais W [ __ ] c'est une ennemi sans
aucun patterne en plus oui un patterne
vous savez forcément ce que c'est c'est
le chemin prédéfini que va prendre un
ennemi et qui permet au joueurs de
savoir comment se placer pour l'éviter
et là cet ennemi ainsi que tous les
autres ennemis du même type n'ont aucun
patterne ils sont libres de faire
n'importe quoi [ __ ] mais regardez ces
trajectoires de l'enfer ça veut
strictement rien
dire comment je suis censé éviter ça
bordel ça arrive de tous les côtés
regarde z c'est
l'humiliation c'est pas dur quand je
vous mets les deux écrans à côté bon jeu
mauvais jeu merde vous savez débuter un
jeu vidéo c'est comme un premier
rendez-vous les premiers regards les
premiers mots ça compte c'est important
c'est les premières impression là c'est
techniquement les premières secondes que
va passer le joueur avec sa manette dans
les mains et le premier enemi que tu
croises c'est un truc qui traverse
l'écran en
0,37 secondes no joke j'ai vérifié
37 secondes premier ennemi du jeu
bienvenue dans Indiana Jones tu vas rter
du sang [ __ ] ok vous savez quoi c'est
nul fait chaud on transpire les singes
veulent te tuer on va plutôt commencer
par un truc plus calme plus tranquille
qui symbolise le calme le bien-être
genre le
Tibet non pas le Tibet ah non pas ce
cauchemar qui recommence
non oh mon dieu le Tibet non pourquoi un
si beau pays a été autant victime détron
vidéo ah mais merde c'est inévitable
sérieux 8 secondes 8 secondes j'ai fait
dans ce niveau
allez tu te fous de ma gueule tu te fous
de ma gueule ma chaussure est plus large
que le trou bon allez le Tibet ça
comptait pas de toute façon je savais
que c'était une mauvaise idée allez
j'essaye un autre l'Égypte et oui voilà
évidemment tout le monde sait que les
Égyptiens au 20e siècle sont habillés
comme les anciens pharaons ça m'énerve
les gens qui font des stéréotypes comme
ça
bon bref alors ce niveau donc dans ce
niveau il va
falloir jouer
contre le vent bon monsieur s'il vous
plaît il faut partir on est dans un
niveau sur l'Égypte
[Musique]
là bon bref allez oublion que
Jean-Michel jar est à la sono et jouant
au jeu donc il faut avancer dans les
trous et sauter dedans rapidement parce
queà intervalle régulier le vent se met
à souffler et vous pousse dedans en
arrière évidemment ça n'est pas un
simple élément de gameplay ils ont bien
sûr pensé à le rendre complètement mal
foutu
allez non j'étais dedans j'étais dedans
[ __ ] oh là là allez ah voilà oh c'est
what quoi c'est qu' il m'a extirpé hors
du trou c'est quoi ce délire ok vous
savez quoi c'est nul l'Égypte il fait
chaud tout ça on va plutôt mettre
Londres non pas Londres pas ce cauchemar
je n'aime pas le thé je trouve ça fade
non allez l'Angleterre maintenant avec
le retour des oiseaux évidemment [ __ ]
le retour des missiles regardez ça comme
ça plonge dans des angles Imposs
possible c'est n'importe quoi [ __ ]
c'est quoi ces Scud là merde c'est
impossible à tuer je suis en train de me
dé faire défoncer par un piaf et je
tombe dans un trou dans le trou
imaginaire [ __ ] et merde
allez regarde maintenant on passe en
mode punition divine [ __ ] mais c'est
deux fois trois fois je Dieu veut me
tuer c'est la c'est la punition de Dieu
[ __ ] de niveau de
merde allez retour en Inde au pays des
singes ninjas fou qu'est-ce que dégage
[ __ ] et des oiseaux et oui les oiseaux
les
singes est-ce que ça se voit que je
passe un mauvais moment là est-ce que ça
se voit [ __ ] mais regardez ça mais
c'est fou je suis bloqué dans le coin
gauche de l'écran de démarrage je me
fais littéralement défragmenter la
gueule à coup de Babouche et j'arrive
même pas à le toucher avec mon arme de
merde mais c'est pas vrai qui m'a foutu
une arme pareille mais regarde je touche
personne regardez c'est quoi cette arme
de merde là c'est un fouet ou c'est un
ruban de gym
artistique regardez ça là je touche rien
je touche rien je tue
personne c'est sûr que quand tu vois le
jeu la première fois tu te dis ça a
l'air génial le fouet a l'air super
flexible ça ne peut être que mieux que
les classiques fouets dans les autres
jeux qui ne font que H directions c'est
comme les beats dans les consoles rétro
he plus il y en a mieux c'est n'est-ce
pas ma fille de laatar Jaguar non ah
mais couilles ouais la seule hitbox du
fouet c'est-à-dire le seul truc pris en
compte pour tuer les ennemis c'est là là
sur l'extrême
bout pointu alors tu peux bien agiter ça
dans tous les sens en essayant
désespérément de survivre en mode chaîne
nébulaire ça ne sert à rien parce que
tout ça là ça n'a aucune existence
physique dans le
[Musique]
jeu je sais pas je m'en vais là la
musique était finie alors je m'étais dit
que non et si je mets ça
[Musique]
ok vous voulez pas me laisser partir
c'est ça bon et bien mon voyage en enfer
continue parce que oui l'enfer c'est
clairement la chose qui se rapproche le
plus de ce jeu parce que en enfer comme
dans ce jeu on ne te laisse pas mourir
non ta barre de vie dans ce jeu elle est
juste gigantesque tu peux passer des
heure à rebondir et à te faire later les
couilles par tout le monde sans que le
jeu ne t'accorde la douce délivrance du
Game Over qui te donne une excuse pour
arrêter le jeu il veut pas que tu meures
le jeu il veut te garder le plus
longtemps possible pour continuer à te
torturer et je pense que ce jeu fait
partie de cette catégorie de jeu où les
développeurs savaient que c'était nul et
savaiit que tu prenais des coups tout le
temps et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont mis
une barre de vie longue parce que sinon
les joueurs se seraient arrêtés à la
première mort et du coup vu que tu es
condamné à ne pas mourir et que tu ne
peux pas tuer les ennemis non plus parce
que ton fouet est à chier ben du coup
les ennemis ils s'accumulent ils
s'accumulent de plus en plus et tu te
fais littéralement tout le temps toucher
par quelque
chose regardez ça
ah je ne contrôle plus rien
je ne contrôle plus rien le jeu me viole
j'ai pas d'autre mot le jeu est en train
de me violer qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se
passe si tuas besoin d'un coup de main
moi évidemment en plus vu que tu passes
pas une seconde sans te faire toucher
par un ennemi que c'est comme d'ab cap
connard qui a développé le jeu où est-ce
qu'ils ont foutu l'objectif du niveau
tout en haut
évidemment merde
merde merde merde merde non tu je te
déteste tellement mais tellement [ __ ]
ce singe fou qui fait n'importe quoi en
bas non tu je l'esquiver ta sœur en
enfer non mais vas-y passe-moi la
banette tu as besoin
d'aide regardez ça mon perso il devient
fou je suis al ver l'hélicoptère
maintenant et moi je vais bientôt
devenir raou le maoule
[Musique]
[ __ ] et en plus ce niveau il demande
de la concentration et comment tu veux
te concentrer avec ce se qui fait ça en
[Musique]
permanence bon ok aide-moi tiens ah ben
bravo voilà ça sert à rien de dire que
tu veux m'aider si c'est pour pas mettre
du tien et vous savez c'est qu'en plus
tout ce que je vous montre là ça n'est
que la première partie des niveaux
évidemment ça n'est que l'entrée tenez
par exemple dans l'Égypte une fois que
vous avez passé le passage avec le vent
vous arrivez donc dans une pyramide
égyptienne avec tout ce qui va avec des
dieux qui crachent du feu des des yeux
Illuminatis des pièges mortels enfin
bref l'endroit idéal pour faire un
échange de technologie on peut pas faire
ça chez moi plutôt chez tes
[Musique]
cacahuètes en plus je sais pas visible
ils ont pas besoin d'avoir une Gat
[ __ ] ils onant qui crache du feu merde
bon bref de toute façon ce niveau j'ai
pas réussi très sincèrement j'ai essayé
mais c'est mort déjà regardez premier
étage 2è
étage 3è étage toujours pas compris ce
qui va pas bah alors attendez je vous
mets autre niveau ça sera peut-être plus
évident donc Londres prier étage 2e
étage 3e étage 4e étage 5e étage vous
voyez la différence moi non plus c'est
parce qu'il y en a pas tous les étages
sont les mêmes oui on a un gagnant pour
prendre une belle grosse merde il faut
de l'incompétence mais il faut aussi
surtout être un [ __ ] de gros flémard
que ce soit au Tibet en Égypte le pire
c'est dans Londres dans chaque niveau
les deuxièm parties de chaque niveau
sont juste le même cycle d'étage
purement et simplement copier-collé qui
se répèteent les uns auudessus des
autres bravo mais tellement bravo ce jeu
est juste parfait merci mais je tiens à
remercier toute notre équipe de
production c'est la trè fois qu'il est
nommé employé du mois [ __ ] déployer un
tel level de branlage de couille à ce
niveau-l c'est limite du sport je vous
le dis si tu as la patience donc d'aller
jusqu'au bout de niveau tu arrives au
boss évidemment chaque boss c'est la
même chose pourquoi on se fatiguerit à
chaque fois tu arrives au boss et tu
vois le professeur whos là qui donne la
technologie un agent allemand ce qui est
complètement débile quand on y pense Prz
prenez cette technologie secrète et dans
une semaine rendez-vous en Himalaya où
je vous donnerai la
suivante oh merci mais vous pouvez pas
me donner suivante tout de suite plutôt
non j'ai dit un himbalaya et la
prochaine je vous la donnerai sur la
lune et d'ailleurs entreidé de génie peu
importe si vous arrivez sur un niveau
avec 2 milliards de vies si le timer
arrive à zéro même si vous avez tué le
boss la mission est t échoué impossible
de la refaire dans tous les jeux du
monde ça te ferait juste perdre une vie
et tu recommencerais mais non ici va te
faire mettre tu as perdu et ben tu as
perdu et pourtant c'est étrange parce
que même si vous échouez une mission
vous pouvez quand même accéder au
dernier niveau emagne d'ailleurs sur le
Zepelin du niveau final on voit toutes
les armes qu'on est censé avoir empêché
les Allemands de récupérer alors est-ce
que ça voudrait dire que c'est une
mécanique de gameplay du genre par
exemple si les armes ne marchent pas en
fonction du nombre de missions que j'ai
réussi par exemple ça voudrait dire que
la mission de fin est plus simple en
fonction du nombre de technologies que
j'ai empêché les Allemands de
récupérer non toutes les armes marchent
sans aucun problème les Allemands
absolument toutes les technologies que
vous les avez empêché
d'avoir tout ce que vous avez fait à
travers le monde n'a servi à rien et
c'est pas fini l'écran de fin du jeu
c'est le même qu'au début avec un [ __ ]
de sprite à moin le même écran à moins
bien de la première seconde du jeu
jusqu'à la dernière seconde de l'écran
titre ce jeu n'aura été qu'un colossal
et douloureux agrandissement rectal
alors si vous voulez une conclusion à ce
test je n'ai qu'une chance à déclarer ça
sera et
encore lâche-moi espèce de T lâchemoi
lâche-moi [ __ ] de jeu [ __ ] de
console et [ __ ] de livr qui sert à
rien
attends ce plan cette forêt ce temple
maill j'ai déjà vu quelque part c'est à
côté de la
[Musique]
boulangerie PAP vous tes vivant je pens
que les all av en
44 tu maintenant je peux en
quitis je ne suis pas
vra NAS jamais noté les initiales de mon
nom archibel bon
gr a v G n oh merde vous voulez dire
alpha 5 jalganik de la planète
jalganox cela fait plusieurs millénaires
que je suis bloqués ici merci de m'avoir
apporté la clé de contact de mon
vaisseau SP cel maintenant je dois y
aller car je suis le 7è héritier de
l'empire détenteur de l'énergie jaune
qui nous aidera à vaincre les ennemis
terribles qui ravagent ma galaxie les
Chinois rien à voir avec vre je dois
partir merci mon ami je ne t'oublierai
jamais et bien me rendre visite un
jour regarde chinois
[Musique]